in this video we are going to present
the entire timeline of monsterverse
godzilla
and also his members or to be exact the
history
of the titanos gojira species we have
done a previous video on the entire
monsterverse timeline but with new
information
from the teasers and trailers of
godzilla vs kong
and also the novelizations and comics
even from the upcoming
godzilla dominion and kingdom kong we
have decided now to compile everything
and put up a more complete backstory and
timeline of only the titanic's gojira
species
the ones that include godzilla and dagon
and maybe more so strap yourself
up for a journey through time in the
monster universe and do let us know
about your thoughts on the matter
so let's do it roughly 300 million years
ago or maybe more than that
the titans which include godzilla uh
comes into existence how the evolve is
yet to be explained
but i suspect that this knowledge will
be lost in time
250 million years ago a shinomura landed
upon a small island to feast upon the
remains of a large aquatic creature
it failed to notice godzilla and was
subsequently blasted by his atomic
breath
leading to it falling underground and
laying dormant there for millions of
years
250 million years ago around the same
time that the shinomura was attacked by
godzilla
a meteorite strike hit the earth
resulting in drastic changes in
radiation levels around the world
this led to the permian extinction event
and the titans going underground to feed
on the remaining radiation that lies in
there
50 000 bc fast forwarding millions of
years we reached a time when
primitive man had just discovered fire
and apparently aren't
and with this they had cave paintings
that depicts the titans
including godzilla 50 000 bc
it was probably at this time that
monster zero descended upon the surface
of the planet
and this resulted in a battle with
godzilla and mothra
in which the earth's protectors won and
ghidorah was trapped in the antarctic
ice
30 000 bc around this time the chauvet
pond dog cave in southern france
has its wall painted by the upper
paleolithic homo sapiens
depicting a number of animals of which
the earliest record painting of godzilla
was seen
thirty thousand to ten thousand bc
various ancient human civilizations
emerged and each one of them
lived alongside and worshiped a titan
found
in their own region and one of which was
atlantis and it had godzilla as a
protector 1100 bc
in ancient japan the mutual prime versus
dagon battle took place
which led to dagon being defeated and
muted spores injected into his body
which would serve as the genesis of
godzilla 2014 storyline
1502 a.d the hopfer etching was created
in augsburg germany
depicting shinomura and godzilla it took
many months for monarch
in the present time to extract the part
of the etching painting
of the two mutos which are rayleigh
shinimura and godzilla
from the vatican iscariot organization
1943 a.d the uss lauren was attacked and
sunken by unknown reasons
however it may be hinted that the u.s
ship was destroyed by godzilla
and the entire crew was killed during
the incident but only bill randall
survived
1945 a.d during the permian period the
shinomura's body fell into the resulting
fissure from the meteorite crash
there it remains until 1945 when it was
aroused from his slumber
by the detonation of an atomic bomb in
hiroshima
and with this godzilla also awakened to
hunt it down
1946 till 1952 godzilla and the
shinomura fight around the world
with every successive time the shinomura
manages to get away from the big g
this includes in the philippines in 1946
new zealand in 1949
and london in 1952
1954 at the bikini at all the castle
bravo nuclear device is announced as a
testing exercise
but was actually an attempt to kill both
the two shinomuras
and godzilla which results in
successfully killing
one of the chinos but in fact empowering
the g-man and this helped godzilla in
killing the other
1999 dagon skeleton was discovered
following a mind collapse in the
philippines
as with the remains of the muto spores
laid in him
then ishiro sarizawa and vivienne graham
would be present overlooking the
creature's massive ribs and remains
2014 the murders emerged from their
cocoons and resumed their life cycle
of mating which included mating calls
and this was picked up by godzilla their
enemy
and this all leads to the events of
godzilla 2014
in which there were battles around the
world and ended up in san francisco
where
godzilla kills both of them 2014 the
muta prime resurfaces and attacks a
naval base in guam
attracted to the payloads of the nuclear
submarine stationed there
and then godzilla arrives to fight it
and then the prime escapes
this happens again and again in siberia
france and portugal
and ending in montana united states with
godzilla killing it
2015 onwards castle bravo station is
created and the orca device is being
perfected as well as tracking
of the titans by signatures in acoustics
started and with this
godzilla is being secretly monitored and
tracked by monarch
2019 with emma russell and alan jonah in
possession of the orca device
the awakening of the titans begin which
included awakening
king ghidorah and this led to a battle
with godzilla in the antarctic
and also off the coast of mexico
same year 2019 with his near death and
revival by a nuclear device detonated by
serizawa
godzilla makes his way to boston and
battles against monster zero
and with mothra's help he transforms
into his burning form
and defeats the three-headed dragon
2019 after the battle and the crowning
of godzilla as king of the masters
news clippings show that godzilla is in
fact keeping the other tyrants in check
against destroying human cities and
settlements
also 2019 around that time godzilla
swims through the pacific ocean
as he is swimming around the world
because he is the king of the monsters
and the king of the ocean and this
reveals that his radiation
is in fact bringing life back to the
reefs with fish populations increasing
in a logarithmic rate
2020 the events of godzilla dominion
comics
which is a story told entirely from
godzilla's point of view
the graphic novel brings new insights
into the king of the monsters
his habitats ancient rivalries
challenges
and encounters with new titans in the
year before gvk
this includes the rise of the titans
against godzilla
2020 events of kingdom come this is
another comic that will be released
around march
and this would center around kong and
the camazotz
but at the same time prepare the ape for
a future conflict with the king of the
monsters
2020 till 2021 although unconfirmed as
to which year it will be based on
most likely 2021 the events of godzilla
vs kong would usher in a new future
for both mankind and monster alike and
with that we come to the end of the
video
do like for support smash that subscribe
button and slap slap slap that bell
button for
regular updates on master vs content and
the
sections of godzilla vs kong videos
till the next one take care fam
[Music]
you